[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild das sind die letzten Sekunden des
Amokläufers von Winnenden rTL zeigt
heute exklusiv das gesamte zweiminütige
Amateurvideo aufgenommen mit einem Handy
Ort der Parkplatz die letzte Station der
brutalen
amtur alle von Polizisten unschlüssig
läuft er hin und her LT seine Waffe noch
einmal nach in diesem Moment trifft ein
gezielter Schuss sein Wein Tim kretschm
sagt zusammen bleibt am Boden liegen
regungslos jetzt ist ihm offenbar klar
er hat keine Chance mehr zu entkommen er
sieht nur einen Ausweg er setzt zum
letzten Schuss an setzt seinem Leben ein
Ende der Amoklauf von Winden das war
also 2009 medientechnisch und auch
medienpolitisch in einer Zeitenwende ich
meine mit dem iPhone hatte ja gerade
erst die ERA des Smartphones begonnen
nämlich 2007 2 Jahre vorher und auch die
Videoabteilung bei uns bei Bild war noch
ganz klein Youtube war 4 Jahre jung und
dieser armoglauf war eines der ersten
Großereignisse in Deutschland wo das
Internet plötzlich so wichtig war aber
eben längst nicht so wie
heute die Stimme von Stefan Netzeband
die kennt ihr hier aus Tatort
Deutschland in unserem heutigen Fall
tritt er aber als sowas wie ein Zeit auf
der Tag über den wir heute sprechen das
war der 11 märz 2009 ich bin Tony haer
und mein Name ist Mirko Kasimir schön
dass ihr dabei seid
hallo Winnenden liegt 20 km nordöstlich
von Stuttgart und hat etwa 28 000
Einwohner die alberville Realschule
sieht in etwa aus wie man sich so eine
Schule halt vorstellt fantasielose
flachdachbauten weiße Flächen schwarze
Fenster eine bege Turnhalle
hier passiert morgens etwas das den
nachrichtenjournalisten aber sofort
alarmiert guten Tag meine Damen und
Herren ein Amokläufer hat heute morgen
in einer Realschule in Baden-Würtemberg
um sich geschossen die Lage ist im
Moment noch sehr unübersichtlich nach
Angaben der Polizei hat der Mann
mindestens zwei Menschen getötet mehrere
wurden verletzt dem Täter gelang
offenbar die Flucht in die Innenstadt
der amoklaufereignete sich in Winnenden
in der Nähe von Stuttgart Kollegen sind
im Moment noch nicht vor Ort es gibt
auch noch keine Bilder von dort wir sind
deshalb jetzt telefonisch verbunden mit
meinem Kollegen Thomas densel Herr
densel was lässt sich zum Ablauf der Tat
im Moment sagen im Moment kann ich das
nur aus der Ferne beurteilen wir wollen
uns im Moment auf den Weg machen nach
Winnenden ganz einfach erst jetzt weil
wir bis vor kurzem nicht wussten wo das
ganze passiert
ist als die Tagesschau am Morgen diese
Sonderausgabe sendet ist die Lage schon
viel schlimmer als es der Öffentlichkeit
t das tödliche Drama beginnt um 9:30 Uhr
der ehemalige Schüler Tim kretschm
betritt die alberaville Realschule in
wineden mit einer 9 mm Pistole des
Fabrikats Beretta 92 aus dem
Waffenschrank seines Vaters in zwei
Klassenzimmern und einem Chemiesaal
schießt er damit auf Schüler und
Lehrerinnen die er dort antrifft ein
Schüler sech Schülerinnen und eine
Lehrerin erliegen noch vor Ort ihren
Verletzungen
sterben auf dem Weg ins Krankenhaus neun
weitere Schülerinnen und eine Lehrerin
werden verletzt in Sicherheit
gebracht der erste Notruf geht schon um
9:33 Uhr bei der Polizei ein er kommt
per Handy von einem Schüler der
Journalist Peter schwarz vom
Zeitungsverlag weiblingen FST den
darauffolgenden Einsatz so zusammen die
Winnender Polizisten Sebastian Wolf
Tobias Obermüller und Thomas schnf sind
normale Streifenbeamte keine Kräfte ein
Einsatzkommandos aber sie haben einen
Fortbildungskurs der Polizeidirektion
weiblingen absolviert wie kann ich in
extrem Situationen unter hoher
Eigengefährdung einen erstzugriff machen
ohne zu zögern gehen die drei Beamten in
die Schule aus dem ersten Stock hören
sie Schüsse eine Gestalt feuert von oben
auf sie und flieht in einem
Klassenzimmer findet die Polizei fünf
Tote Jugendliche in einem zweiten vier
Opfer zwei sind tot zwei werden später
ihren Verletzungen erliegen durch die
geschlossene Tür zum Physikraum hat der
Attentäter eine Lehrerin erschossen und
auf dem Flur bei seiner Flucht zwei
weitere Lehrkräfte umgebracht Jacqueline
h Stephanie K Selina m Victoria m Nicole
n Chantal s Jana s Christina S und
Ibrahim h Michaela K Nina m und Sabrina
S 12 Menschenleben wärend die Polizisten
nicht so schnell eingeschritten hätte es
noch mehr Opfer
gegeben fassungslos und panisch
verfolgen die Bürger in Winnenden den
Großeinsatz am Schulzentrum und
schildern ihre Eindrücke einem Reporter
des
schwarzwelderboten war irgende zner
klasse aber wir haben auf jeden Fall was
gehört wir haben im Schüssel gehört ja
die sind alle aus dem Fenster raus ja
wir haben gesehen von hinten total
fertig die ganze Kinder sind im hunibad
also die was mir jetzt K und me hat mich
angerufen und ich bin die
kummel es ist absolut schlimm genug was
bis hierhin passiert ist aber der Tag
ist noch nicht zu Ende und Täter Tim
kretschm noch nicht gefasst auf seinem
Weg durch den Park beim Zentrum für
Psychiatrie erschießt er den
Bediensteten Franz Josef J der den
Abfluss am Ententeich reinigt eine
großfandung der Polizei läuft an bald
sind rund 800 Kräfte im Einsatz die
Polizei überwacht alle Schulen der
Gegend und durchstreift die Stadt aber
Täter tim kretschm ist längst wieder
unterwegs der 17-Jährige ist Richtung
Innenstadt gelaufen und zwingt dort
einen Autofahrer mit der Waffe ihn
mitzunehmen zusammen fahren die beiden
über die Bundesautobahn 81 etwa 100
Kilom weit über Tübingen Nürtingen und
die Bundesstraße 313 in Richtung
Wendlingen am Wendlinger Kreuz endet die
Fahrt dramatisch und hektisch der
Autofahrer sieht eine
polizeisperrecht auf ein Streifen reißt
die Tür auf und entkommt Tim Kretschmer
flieht zu Fuß er rennt ins
Industriegebiet von Wendlingen und
erreicht schließlich ein Autohaus in
dessen Räumen erschießt er den Verkäufer
Dennis P und den Kunden sigur W die
Polizei ist dem jungen Amokläufer längst
dicht auf den Fersen als der nach den
jüngsten beiden Morden aus dem Autohaus
kommt es gibt einen Schusswechsel mit
dem Beamten Tim wird am Bein verletzt
geht wieder ins Haus kommt wieder raus
und trifft seinerseits zwei Polizisten
dabei verletzt er eine Beamtin und ihren
Kollegen schwer mittlerweile ist es etwa
12:30 Uhr als Tim kretchm seine
Ausweglosigkeit begriffen hat richtet er
die Waffe gegen sich selbst Zeugen
Filmen das Geschehen aus dem Autohaus
[Musik]
heraus Selen Sel ja ja die Augenzeugen
tauschen sich aus haben Sie den erledigt
fragte eine der hat sich selber
erschossen antwortet ein anderer ein
erschütterndes augenzeugenvideo aber
noch weit entfernt von dem was heute
wohl üblich wäre unser Kollege und
langjähriger videoexperte Stefan
Netzeband dieses Video das kam damals
gegen Abend auf den Markt und wurde dann
ganz schnell von den Kollegen von RTL
exklusiv gekauft es war mit einem Handy
gefilmt worden wie das sie damals eben
gab also ein Siemens vielleicht oder ein
Nokia das war ein quadratförmiger
Bildzuschnitt ganz miese Auflösung
unverständlicher Klang und viel mehr
kursierte nach diesem grauenhaften Tag
auch nicht also wir waren weit entfern
davon dass hunderte mit ihren
Smartphones das Geschehen dann also
quasi liveestamten sondern die meisten
Bilder kam ganz klassisch daher wie man
eben Fernsehen gemacht hat damals
abschwerbänder Polizeisprecher einzelne
augenzeug und das bedeutete für uns
online Journalisten da gab es wesentlich
weniger Videos als heute und damit
positiverweise auch weniger grenzwertige
Filme oder gar Fake News oder so
Zweifelsfälle und wie sich zeigt sitzt
der Schock auch ohne eine solche
Bilderflut tief genug als die Tagesschau
schließlich um 20 Uhr den Tag
zusammenfasst gibt es an der Größen
Ordnung des Schreckens keinen Zweifel
mehr ein amläufer hat in badenwürzemberg
15 Menschen erschossen der 17-Jährige
tötete zunächst in seiner ehemaligen
Realschule neun Schüler und drei Lehrer
auf der Flucht erschoss der Jugendliche
drei weitere Menschen nach Erkenntnissen
der Polizei brachte er sich danach
selbst um die ersten Schüsse fielen am
Morgen etwa 20 km von Stuttgart entfernt
und zwar in der knapp 28 000 Einwohner
zählenden stad Winnenden in der alberv
Realschule in den nächsten Tagen wird
aus dem Eingangsbereich der alberville
Realschule ein einziges Blumenmeer mit
Kerzen dazwischen Psychologen und
Sozialarbeiter versuchen in der
Folgezeit den geschockten Schülern Halt
zu geben vor allem aber fragt sich das
Land wie es schon wieder zu einem so
schrecklichen Amoklauf an einer Schule
kommen konnte das Stichwort war Erfurt
der Amoklauf am dortigen Guttenberg
Gymnasium hatte Deutschland im April
2002 erschüttert also erst knapp 7 Jahre
zuvor auch diesen Fall gibt es bei
Tatort Deutschland ihr findet ihn unter
der amuklauf von Erfurt und darin ist
auch zu hören dass nach dem Blutbad das
der Täter Robert Steinhäuser angerichtet
hatte unter anderem die Waffengesetze
verschärft worden waren und eben auch
die Richtlinien der Polizei und
tatsächlich handelte die Polizei in
winenden ja schneller und entschlossener
aber wie hatte Tim kretschma bloß so
problemlos Zugang zur Waffe haben können
schnell gerät der Vater ins Visier von
Ermittlern und Öffentlichkeit er war
Sportschütze und hatte 15 angemeldete
Waffen zu Hause 14 davon waren korrekt
in einem Tresor verschlossen eine lag im
Schlafzimmer und diese eine nicht
verschlossene Waffe eine baretta 92 samt
passender Munition nahm Tim kretschm
schließlich am Morgen des 11 märz 2009
mit in seine ehemalige Schule eine
weitere Spur gab es Anzeichen dafür dass
Tim eine Grenze überschreitet dass er
gefährlich für andere werden konnte im
Nachhinein sind alle immer Sch Dauer
aber es ist schon bemerkenswert dass der
17-Jährige zwischen April und September
2008 zu mehreren Beratungstermin in der
Psychiatrie Weinsberg erschienen beim
ersten Gespräch berichtete er er werde
vom quälenden Gedanken heimgesucht
Menschen erschießen zu wollen die
behandelnden sagen darin offenbar keine
Gefahr keine so akute zumindest dass
jemand die Polizei
einschaltete die Mitschuld des Vaters
wird später schließlich vor Gericht
verhandelt er wird in zweiter Instanz zu
einer Bewährungsstrafe
verurteilt aber letztendlich hat Tim
kretschm die möglichen Antworten auf das
warum mit in den Tod genommen umso
wichtiger dass bei der Bewältigung des
Horrors buchstäblich alle Hand in Hand
gehen hier noch mal aus der Chronik des
Reporters Peter schwarz die verlinken
wir euch auch noch mal in den
showotes 21 märz
2009 in der katholischen Stadtkirche St
KL boromeus findet eine Trauerfeier
statt die auch ins Herbert winterstadion
und Kirchen und Hallen im Landkreis
übertragen wird die Polizei zählt allein
in Winnenden 8500 Trauergäste darunter
Bundeskanzlerin Angela Merkel und
Vizekanzler frankwalter Steinmeier
Bundespräsident Horst Köhler findet
Worte die vielen aus der Seele
sprechen ja wir haben Angst und wir sind
ratlos aber solange wir einander halten
und helfen können sind wir nicht
hilflos eindringlicher ist der Beitrag
von Schülern unter Motto ich habe einen
Traum stellen sie Symbole in der Kirche
auf ein Herz für die Liebe Hände für
Hilfsbereitschaft Fußabdrücke für den
Weg in die
Zukunft und wie schon bei dem
Geiseldrama von Gladbeck in den 1980ern
oder eben beim Amoklauf in Erfurt gibt
es auch 2009 eine Debatte über die Rolle
der Medien die sein wie Heuschrecken im
beschaulichen Winden eingefallen von CNN
über das ZDF bis
aljasera einzelne Reporter hätten
Schüler belästigt oder einfach Fotos von
Opfern im Internet besorgt und
selbstverständlich muss auch Bild sich
der Kritik stellen damals wie heute noch
mal Stefan Netzeband wir sind damals
unter anderem sehr gescholten worden
weil wir den Hergang in der Schule mit
einer videografik nachgezeichnet haben
ich finde die Kritik im Nachhinein auch
berechtigt also zumindest am Zeitpunkt
der Veröffentlichung so früh nach dem
armoklauf konnte man damals tatsächlich
nur unnötig Gefühle verletzen aber auf
der anderen Seite ganz ehrlich wann
immer Dinge wie in Winden passieren will
die Öffentlichkeit ja auch Bescheid
wissen man will Anteilnehmen man will
Ursachen kennen und Abläufe man will
auch wissen wie man sich schützen kann
und deshalb gibt es immer wieder
Entscheidung in diesem Spannungsfeld ich
sag mal zwischen Pietät und
Rücksichtnahme auf der einen Seite und
Transparenz auf der anderen
journalistischer Transparenz und das
wird immer immer wieder neu
ausverhandelt er ist recht heute wo im
Prinzip ja jeder mit seinem Smartphone
ein ein Videoreporter sein kann und ich
glaube heute würde man vielleicht auch
anders über solche videografiken
diskutieren als damals im Jahr
2009 am Eingang der alberville
Realschule erinnern seit 2012
Steinplatten an die Opfer des
Amoklaufs außerdem wurde aus einem der
Klassenzimmer in dem am 11 märz 2009
Schüler erschossen wurden ein Gedenkraum
hier stehen 15 leere Pulte jedes
versehen mit einem Foto eines Opfers
unweit der Schule steht seit mehr als
Jahren außerdem eine Skulptur in Form
eines gebrochenen Ringes die Inschrift
lautet wenn uns eineignnis fassungslos
macht die Worte im Hals ersticken wir
uns an den Händen fassen und einen Kreis
bilden wenn nur noch Symbole die
Sprachlosigkeit überwinden sind wir an
unseren Grenzen
angelangt
und damit sind wir am Ende unserer
heutigen Episode wir haben diese Folge
mit dem Archiv von Bild Sowi der schon
erwähnten Chronik aus dem Hause zvw
erzählt Skript Stefan Netzeband
Postproduktion schwarz audio berlin
Aufnahme und schnitt Tony haer wir
danken euch fürs zuhören und freuen uns
wenn ihr auch beim nächsten Mal wieder
mit dabei seid falls Ihr Anregungen
Kritik oder fallvorschläge habt dann
schreibt uns gern eine Nachricht bei
Instagram oder eine E-Mail oder schickt
uns eine WhatsApp die Infos dazu findet
ihr in den showotes bis dahin euer Milko
und eure
Ton die hat diese Folge von tout
Deutschland gefallen du bekommst von
True Crime einfach nicht genug dann hör
jetzt in unsere weiteren Folgen rein
hier warten mehr als 200 spannende Fälle
auf dich wie das Verschwinden von
Rebecca Rusch der Prozess gegen OJ
Simpson oder die Entführung von Hermann
wir hören uns bei Tat Deutschland